a droid-filled city features prominently
in the new episode of the Mandalorian
and one of those background Bots even
had a bit part in The Empire Strikes
Back here's the throwback robot Cameo
you may have missed season 3 of the
Mandalorian picks up where we last left
off that is provided you've watched the
din jaran bits of the book of Boba Fett
and know what he and grogu have been up
to as is the series custom it also
features numerous nods at the many Canon
and non-canon stories from the history
of the galaxy far far away in other
words the season 3 premiere features
lots of cool droids the most prominent
of them is of course ig-11 whose
self-destruction sequence in season 1
apparently wasn't enough to entirely
demolish his body and who Mando is now
trying to get revived for the sake of
having some reliable ish backup on his
upcoming Mandalore jaunt I need him back
ig11 was destroyed on the Lava River
this is just a statue however the
episode's backdrop of these surprisingly
spruced up Navarro City plenty of other
mechanical Marvels to behold from the
tiny droids hauling grief cargas Cape to
various protocol droids in fact one of
these cameos just so happens to Mark the
unexpected return of a long-lost
deep-cut character from the Star Wars
lore early on in the episode DIN and
grogu are walking the streets of the
city taking in the sights and marveling
at the overhaul a lot has changed around
here on their way they briefly pass a
bright white protocol Droid that a few
hardcore fans will no doubt recognize as
k-3po this white-colored Droid
resembling C-3PO first appeared in Star
Wars episode 5 The Empire Strikes Back
as a member of the rebels but he's
mainly been a niche fixture of the Star
Wars Canon Sensen based on this brief
Glimpse it's rather likely that the
monochrome Droid is not actually the
exact same character fans first
witnessed fighting the good fight and
The Empire Strikes Back but the visual
design of the model is still quite
unmistakable apart from his original
movie debut k-3po has popped up in a few
other entries in the franchise he's
gotten some cameos in the Star Wars
Battlefront games featured in a small
role for several of the Lego Star Wars
games and has appeared in a couple other
pieces of secondary and non-canon
franchise material nonetheless the
Mandalorian marks the oft-forgotten
droid's highest profile appearance in
years while the k-3po Droid unit that
appears in the season 3 premiere of the
Mandalorian may not be the same one that
originally appeared in The Empire
Strikes Back some fans May nonetheless
be curious about the role that the
character originally played in the movie
suffice to say it's not a very big one
like his counterpart on the Mandalorian
k-3po is mostly resigned to being a
background character in several scenes
he's seen working with the rebels
equipment at their secret base on the
icy Planet Hoth and he's present when
the iconic Battle of Hoth breaks out of
course this epic Star Wars battle
doesn't really go all that well for the
rebels and k-3po is summarily destroyed
in the chaos during the planet's
evacuation considering that the k-3po on
the Mandalorian in perfect condition and
the show takes place years after The
Empire Strikes Back it's probably not
the same one from the original movie
however destroyed droids like ig-11 have
been brought back to life before so
there's still a possibility these two
units are one and the same if the
Mandalorian ever likes to give this
smaller Star Wars character a bigger
role perhaps fans will finally get a
definitive answer
[Music]